hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa y ya está conmigo lista en el
estudio más romeros a la mar qué bueno
tenerla de nuevo en nuestro programa ya
nos hacía falta estar aquí hablando de
salud vamos a hablar por supuesto de la
micro lamentablemente sigue en los
titulares en este 2022 como lo dijimos
el año pasado repasamos entonces todo lo
que hemos aprendido sobre esa nueva
variante de kobe 19 o lo que no hemos
aprendido más exacto hay un poco de todo
no para empezar es un gusto volver a
estar aquí un gusto volver a
acompañarlos hay una parte negativa de
seguir hablando de omicron como dejamos
2021 y es que claramente seguimos
inmersos en esta pandemia pero hay una
parte positiva y es que esta variante
nueva cada vez es menos nueva y cada vez
tenemos más información para repasar
todo este conocimiento que hemos
acumulado durante este mes mes y medio
estamos con el doctor carlos de eduardo
pérez él es médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y como
cada lunes nos acompaña para resolver
nuestras preguntas y nuestras dudas del
doctor muy buenos días sabemos que o
micro no al menos se dice ser repetido
desde hace mucho tiempo que un micrón
parece generar una enfermedad menos
grave eso se debe a los cambios
intrínsecos en el virus o es que la la
opción estaba más vacunada y está más
preparada también
mar buenos días es una combinación de
los dos es que hay mayor población
inmunizada pero de por si este virus
tiene una menor probabilidad de afectar
los pulmones el hecho de que tengan una
por el menor afectado expone la crisis
afecte otros órganos y que no sea una
enfermedad que pueda ser potencialmente
grave es una reducción en la violencia
es mayor inmunidad en la población pero
sin duda tenemos una ley y una alarma
porque como todos estamos vacunados y
todavía no tenemos una predicción
correcta de lo que pasa con portar el
virus en un futuro doctor un gusto
saludarlo en este año en 2022 y entonces
muchos países han reducido ya el tiempo
de cuarentena doctor me pregunto si los
contagios con omicron duran realmente
menos
raúl muy buenos días y una de las cosas
que hemos aprendido es que este virus
infecta y recordemos que infecta incluso
un día antes de que presenten los
síntomas ahí es uno de los grandes
problemas de las barreras de iu porque
la necesidad de las barreras como el
tapabocas es que se transmite antes de
que la persona se internó y lo que vemos
pues que la extinción de gales son tres
o cuatro días después de la presencia de
los síntomas entonces eso hace que los
cuales los aislamientos que hacíamos
antes por 14 días se pueden producir a 7
días como un día digamos bastante
razonable de acuerdo es aena mi
habilidad hoy utilizamos ese esquema de
siete días y hemos encontrado en las
diferentes partes del mundo que es
efectivo porque hay menor cantidad de
previsión después del tercer tipo bueno
es una buena es una buena noticia
reducir las cuarentenas al final también
se está impulsando las dosis de refuerzo
como una de las medidas para luchar
contra estas nuevas oleadas provocadas
por omicron pero mi pregunta es un poco
hasta cuando no hasta cuándo vamos a
seguir vacunando nos por cada tipo por
cuánto tiempo vamos a tener que seguir
teniendo dosis de refuerzo eso es es
real que pueda seguir manteniéndose así
en el futuro
no lo predecible esta pandemia es que es
impredecible en nosotros no podemos
afirmar que va a pasar en un tiempo de
demostrarnos y esta es una lucha día a
día lo que desierto mar es que si es muy
probable que nosotros miramos e
inmunización frecuente cada seis meses
cada año como sucede con la influenza
nosotros pasamos una expanden a la
influenza y por eso las recomendaciones
de la vacunación anual y en ésta no
sería algo distinto lo que es cierto es
que las vacunas han demostrado cada vez
mayor su efectividad y la probabilidad
de cortar esa cadena de transmisión está
en que todo el planeta no un grupo esté
vacunado entonces es muy probable que
repitamos la vacunación cada seis meses
cada año y que sean mejor el desarrollo
de las vacunas
así que no nos salvamos este año
entonces de poner el brazo otra vez
marco doctor también al inicio esta
crisis o microondas se habló de la
posibilidad de hacer vacunas específicas
contra esta variante de el coronavirus
finalmente si son necesarias o las que
tenemos son suficientes
las vacunas tienen que evolucionar como
evolucionan los medicamentos el
conocimiento estas vacunas que tenemos
son muy buenas pero son vacunas que
todavía le falta aportar la arena
transmisión es tal vez el delito más
importante para frenar la pandemia es
muy probablemente que en este segundo
trimestre tengamos un nuevo diseño de la
reformulación de las vacunas e incluya
esta variante o milton y otras que se
puedan estar desarrollando es decir
hacer una vacuna que sea universal y que
independientemente las variantes pues
sirva para todas las variantes digámoslo
así en eso se está desarrollando y
esperamos que en unos tres a seis meses
ya tengamos noticias al respecto bueno
pues seguiremos pendientes como siempre
aquí la última pregunta se ha augurado
un poco que era el inicio del fin de la
pandemia con esta llegada de la variante
omicron que qué opinión le merece eso
realmente estamos en camino de que el
comité 19 se convierta en una enfermedad
endémica
si es muy probablemente que en el
segundo semestre ya hablemos de algo
endémico eso no quiere decir que no sea
grave es decir que necesitamos estar
vacunando de estarlo monitorizando pero
va a dejar digamos que de esta secuencia
de brotes universales para hacer
protesto cales de acuerdo a la
inmunización es muy probable que en el
segundo semestre este año ya hablemos de
una enfermedad endémica se requieren
tratamientos vacunas que corten la
cadena de transmisión
medicamentos altamente efectivos y sobre
todo y lo más importante acceso a la
tecnología en todo el planeta
no importa si nosotros ponemos con 3 o
560 una región si no lo hace todo el
mundo no va a funcionar
uno de los días más felices de nosotros
dando esa noticia de el fin de la
pandemia para allá que se convierta
nuevamente en una epidemia doctor
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo por
estar como siempre todos los lunes con
nosotros aquí en directo américa gracias
mar ahora vamos a pasar a hablar con
nuestro segundo invitado al día